ne mange pas trop de fromage pourquoi s'il
te plaît ne te libère pas tu es blessé je ne peux pas lui
faire face où étais-tu je suis dans une
relation maman ne peut pas être là tout le
temps
tu ne peux pas juste changer les règles  parce que
quelqu'un Shanon intéressant peut-être que je suis
trop doux avec toi depuis combien de temps connais-tu
Oscar quelques semaines nous avons affaire à
un individu extrêmement dangereux
il y a un tueur qui traque cette île
et tu l'as abandonnée parce que tu
voulais aller faire un tour
il  ne t'aime pas il ne peut pas t'aimer
pense parce que tu chantes dans la chorale tu
peux tromper les gens en leur faisant croire que tu es
quelqu'un d'autre tout ce que tu as fait pour
moi je te pardonne de
sortir c'est toi qui a menti pendant
la  enquête sur plusieurs meurtres
comment pouvez-vous me demander maintenant
et vous gardez un secret
[Musique]